Thank you.
myself comfortable.
Good evening, everyone.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, but I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassam.
Namo dasa bhagavato arahato samma samudasa homage to the buddha the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one so we're moving on now uh we're going back to this character of achagata we met him before earlier on mainly to do with the uh
The thing about the fire.
Anyway, you can revise that if you want.
This last discourse really tells us how he got on.
And he goes to see the Buddha.
He's at the bamboo grove at the squirrel sanctuary in Rajgaha.
Rajagaha, which is now present-day Rajgir, which was the seat of Bimbisara, the king of Magadha on the Ganges there.
So he comes to the Buddha and he says, you know, can you teach me in brief or, yes, can you teach me in brief what is wholesome and what is unwholesome?
So the Buddha replies that he can do both in brief and, of course, in detail.
and uh and then he says listen closely so he basically goes through uh what we already know the um the 10 unwholesome actions so greed is unwholesome now this word greed i've always thought it's better to think of it as um
Acquisitiveness.
So these are your three basic roots.
So mistaking our identity for this human form, we obviously want to try and make ourselves happy.
That's when the acquisitiveness begins.
The money, the people, the fame, the power, the holidays, and so on and so forth.
And then there's the aversion, which remember includes both
a dislike of, a hatred of, and also a fear of, and of course delusion.
And out of these three basic dispositions of acquisitiveness, aversion, and delusion, we have wrongdoing.
So the first three are to do with the body.
So that's killing living beings.
You can extend that to harming them for no good reason.
Taking what is not freely given and misconduct of sensual pleasure.
So normally that's translated as sexual, but it has a much wider meaning of indulgence.
So that's the body.
Then there's speech, which is of course, false speech, malicious speech.
Uh, malicious speech.
Uh, hold on.
I've missed it here.
Where am I?
Uh, all speech, malicious speech.
Um, it should be something else.
Where are we?
Oh yeah.
Uh, abusive speech, abusive speech, and just gossip, just talking for talking sake.
So that's to do with speech.
And then finally to do with the mind thinking it's covetousness, wanting what other people have.
all thoughts of ill will and of course wrong view, wrong understanding which takes us back to these three misunderstandings about impermanence, cause of suffering, this desire and of course not self.
So then
The Buddha says that when somebody abandons all that, it's like the palm stump.
So once you cut the frothy bit at the top of a palm, it just doesn't grow again.
That's it.
All the taints are destroyed.
So if you remember the taints, the oozings, the cankers, sense desire, the desire to keep becoming wrong view.
Sometimes ignorance is put with wrong view, but that seems to me just to double it.
say the same thing really.
So normally it's sense desire becoming, wanting to continue to become, to create this constant self, this selfing and this basic ignorance.
So now Bhakta goes to ask him a question and it seems to be that he's wondering if the Buddha is the only one who's actually enlightened.
So he's got all these moksha, all these nuns, all these lay people, but is he the only one that's actually
fully liberated.
So he asks, he says, is there amongst your monks, anyone who's entered and abide upon the deliverance of mind and the deliverance by wisdom?
The deliverance by mind are the absorptions and the deliverance by wisdom is through the vipassana or through the investigation of the three characteristics.
That's the one that liberates you.
And the Buddha replies, 100 or 200, 300,
Far more monks who, by realizing for themselves with direct knowledge here and now, enter upon and abide in the deliverance of mind and the deliverance by wisdom that are taintless with the destruction of the taints, the usings.
So, first of all, Bhakta wants to know, are there any monks who have been fully liberated?
And the Buddha says, loads of them.
And then he asks, what about the nuns?
And then he asks, is there one lay person clothed in white leading a life of celibacy who with the destruction of the five lower fetters will reappear spontaneously in the pure abodes and there attain final Nibbana without ever returning from that world.
So here we're talking about the non-returner.
So he's not asking if there are any fully liberated
lay people.
He's asking if there are any that have attained the third attainment.
So remember there's the stream entrant, the one who has that initial experience of nirvana.
Then there's the once returner who has a deeper experience, which as it were undermines this greed and acquisitiveness and aversion.
But the non-returner is the one who's left the sensual life as a place to seek happiness.
So he asks, is there any layman who's done that?
And of course, the Buddha says, you know, just so many, 100, 300, 400.
And later on, he asks, is that the same of the women lay followers?
And of course, he says, yes, there are hundreds of them.
And then he asks, is there any one lay follower?
one manly follower, clothed in white, enjoying sensual pleasure, who carries out his instruction, responds to his advice, has gone beyond, become free of perplexity, gained intrepidity, and become independent of others in the teacher's dispensation.
So this is somebody who is a stream entrant, got the first and the second, okay?
These
these people who've attained those two levels obviously still are committed to sensual pleasure as a place to find true happiness so they're not fully liberated and he says well there's hundreds of them too and the same for the women and uh what um what uh uh back to go to then says
if only master gotama were accomplished in this dharma but no monks and later on no nuns no lay men and no lay women then this holy life would be deficient in that respect but because master gotama and the bhikkhus are accomplished in this dharma the holy life is thus complete in that respect so what vajra gota is saying is that
having all these people around him, both monks and lay people, who've attained like this, really substantiates the Buddha's teachings.
And this, of course, then he says, the image, he always gives a little image.
Just as a river Ganges inclines towards the sea, slopes towards the sea, flows towards the sea, and extends all the way to the sea,
so too Master Gautama's assembly, with its homeless ones and its householders, inclines towards Nibbāna, slopes towards Nibbāna, flows towards Nibbāna, and extends all the way to Nibbāna.
So having said that, now Vajragota, although he's been coming to the Buddha for some time, has enough confidence to declare that he actually wants to take the roads.
I go to Master Gautama for refuge to the Dharma and the Sangha Bhikkhus.
I would receive the going forth under Master Gautama.
I would receive the full admission.
So he wants to become a monk.
And then what the Buddha says is, well, anybody who's coming from another teacher, they have to go into a probation period of four months.
but I recognize the individual differences in this matter.
So what he's saying is for you, Vachagatha, you can come straight in.
But Vachagatha is humble enough to say, no, no, I will live on probation for four years.
And at the end of four years, excuse me, he's on probation for four years, not months.
Sorry, the probation is normally four months, but what Vajagota says is, I'll remain in probation for four years.
And at the end of four years, if the bhikkhus are satisfied with me, let them give me the going forth and full admission to the bhikkhu's state.
And so, now not long after that, he goes to see the Buddha.
to teach the Dharma further.
So he's been a monk, he's been in the order, as it were, as a samanera for about four years.
And the Buddha now gives him further developments to lead to the penetration of many elements.
And what he does is he gives him those types of instructions
that lead to the fourth jhāna and above.
Now, at the point of fourth jhāna, and this is what the Buddha sees in Bhaktivinoda, he's able to attain the powers, the higher powers.
And I'm now moving on to number 77.
We've also been here before with Sakyula Yadin.
And we're going to have a quick run through
these abhinya the higher powers so the first one is the mind made body so these these are normally very strange things to us with our very concrete scientific minds so here somebody can create another one of their of themselves their body and mind
and it says it gives it gives uh many of an example but one is this is the sword this is the scabbard the sword is one the scabbard is another it is from the scabbard that the sword has been pulled out and just as a man were to pull the snake out of its skin and think thus this is the snake this is the skin and so on and so forth uh i i uh
My disciples, I have proclaimed to my disciples the way to create from this body another body, having a body, mind made with all its limbs, lacking no faculty.
Now, in other words, that would be appearing in two different places as two different bodies.
Now, you might say to yourself, well, of course, that's ridiculous.
But I would encourage you to read a book about this wonderful Indian woman who was a teacher in the 70s, 80s.
I think she died late last century.
And her name was Dipa Ma, D-I-P-A M-A.
And a book has been written about her by one of her students, Amy Schmidt.
She was also a teacher of the people, you know, like, um, Shannon Salzberg and, um, Joseph Goldstein and people like that.
And, um, she was a Mahazi devotee.
Um, so if you read that book, you'll see actually that she had that power now with the witnesses.
So it's up to you.
You see what, what I say is keep these things on a back burner.
You never know.
Now, the second one is what we would know as astral travelling.
And I know somebody who's done this, so for me it's not absolutely impossible.
But basically it's the mental body which leaves the physical body, and that's happened to one or two of my students.
And that, of course, is a finer material than all this
physical matter, you know, and therefore it can travel wherever it wants.
It can go unhindered through enclosures, through mountains, dive in and out of the earth and so on and so forth.
So that's the second abhinya, that's the second power.
The next one is the divine ear, whereby you can hear things which is not possible through the ordinary physical ear.
The next one is to understand people's minds.
Now, some of you who've been long distance and been with me through these talks might remember the story of the Jungian therapist of the Isle of Man who went to Burma, ended up visiting this old man in a monastery, old monk in a monastery to be taught Buddhism.
And they had a long conversation, two hours or so.
And during that whole time, he never used the interpreter.
And of course he didn't speak a word of Burmese.
So even that is possible too.
Then there's the recollection of past lives.
Now in the Visuddhimagga, that's the path of purification by Buddhadasa, it's a big tome, I've mentioned it before, instructions are given on how to do this.
So what you do is you begin now and you go backwards onto your life, trying to remember as much as you can.
And then you come forward, trying to remember as much as you can.
And as all the memories come back to you, come back to you, come back to you, right to your birth.
And you break through that barrier into the previous life.
So there's actually a methodology that you can do if you want to find out what your past lives were.
The next one is the divine eye.
Now, the thing about the divine eye in terms of the Buddha was that that's what he saw upon enlightenment, upon his awakening.
He saw all his past lives.
Yeah.
But with his divine eye, he was able to see that beings were moving from one realm to another dependent on their moral decisions, upon their ethics.
So this was a direct understanding by him of the importance of morality.
the final one of course the great opinion of them all is the destruction of the tanks that's the biggest of all powers the destruction of the tanks and that of course is a sign that somebody is liberated from all suffering now the one thing you'll notice that's not included in this list is healing which is interesting isn't it don't ask me why um
There's also another book that you might be interested in called The End of Materialism by Taft, T-A-F-T. And in it, there are all these experiments.
The one I remember is being down in a submarine way down there where there is no electromagnetic signal whatsoever and the ability to have that extrasensory perception about what was going on or reading, telling people what was going on now
in the world elsewhere so that's the two books there Deepamar by Amy Schmidt and End of Materialism if you're interested now actually if you were to give me a choice if you were to say would you have any of these powers or would you prefer to compose a Beethoven symphony or a Shakespearean play or a
a Dante-esque poem, I think I'd go for those rather than all these wonderful powers, but then that's just me.
So now we go back to Bachagata and find out what happened to him.
So of course he does develop all these powers.
Dwelling before long, dwelling alone, withdrawn, diligent, ardent and resolute, the venerable Bachogata by realizing for himself with direct knowledge here and now entered upon and abided in that supreme goal of the holy life for the sake of which clansmen rightly go forth from home life into homelessness.
He directly knew birth is destroyed.
The holy life has been lived.
What had to be done has been done.
There is no more coming into any state of becoming.
And the venerable Vajragota became one of the Arahants.
Isn't that a lovely ending?
Now, then he sees these venerable ones on their way somewhere.
And he asks them where they're going.
He says, we're going to see the Blessed One.
And he tells them, say to the Blessed One, the Blessed One has been worshipped by me.
The Blessed One has been worshipped by me.
In other words, I have followed your directions to the end.
Now, when the Bhikkhus say that to the Buddha, the Buddha replies, having encompassed his mind with my own mind, I already knew of the Bhikkhu Vachagoda.
The Bhikkhu Vachagoda has attained the threefold true knowledge and has great supernormal power and might.
The threefold knowledge is, of course, past lives,
seeing how karma works out for other beings and liberation or the cleansing totally of those taints, those oozings.
And the Buddha says, the deities also told me, the Bhaktshagata has attained the threefold true knowledge and has great supernormal power and might.
That is what the blessed ones said.
The Ozbikus were satisfied and delighted in the blessed ones' work.
So a little bit of magic tonight.
I can only hope that this in some way is inspiring for you and that you will continue full steam ahead until you are completely liberated sooner rather than later.
odhanku jaini dhamanku jaini sanganku jaini
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Bodham Saranam Gacchami Dhammam Saranam Gacchami Sangam Saranam Gacchami Tuttyampi Bodham Saranam Gacchami Tuttyampi Dhammam Saranam Gacchami
Duthi Ampi Sanggang Saranam Gacchami Kati Ampi Bodang Saranam Gacchami Kati Ampi Damang Saranam Gacchami Kati Ampi Sanggang Saranam Gacchami
Anathipatha Vairamani Sikapada Samadhi Ami Adhinadhana Vairamani Sikapada Samadhi Ami Kamesumicacara Vairamani Sikapada Samadhi Ami
musavada-veramani-sikapadamsamadhyami surameraya-majjapamadakana-veramani-sikapadamsamadhyami
So making sure that our body is the expression of the awakened one.
Using those muscles in the lower back and the abdomen, lifting ourselves up, up the spine, sitting tall.
A moment of relaxation.
The brow.
and the jaw.
Shoulders.
Just acknowledging the posture, energised, up the spine, everything else, relax.
This body is subject to disease.
This body is of a nature to fall ill.
This body has not gone beyond sickness.
This body is subject to aging.
This body has not gone beyond aging.
This body is now in a process of aging.
This body is subject to death
This body has not gone beyond death.
This body will die.
There is the unborn, undying, uncreated, uncompounded.
The unconditioned,
True refuge, harbour and home.
Perfect peace and contentment.
Those who are mindful are in the presence of Nibbana.
Settling on the breath and then opening up to whatever draws the attention within that field of awareness.
Just watching, just feeling, just experiencing.
Intimately.
It's enough.
Moments reflection Resolution
So make sure you're sitting comfortably for our evening contemplations.
Turn into our own hearts, speaking gently.
May I be free of physical pain.
May I be free of mental distress.
May I be liberated of all my sufferings.
Bringing to mind someone we know is having a hard time.
May you be free of physical pain.
May you be free of mental distress.
May you be liberated of all your sufferings.
And all those at this moment who are sick and or suffering from mental illness, people in the process of dying, and those who have died and left grieving family, relatives and friends.
People going hungry, homeless and death destitute.
Those having to deal with severe personal and interpersonal difficulties.
All those who've been victims of prejudice,
All those caught up in wars and repressive regimes and those being tortured.
And there are those suffering from natural disasters and climate crisis.
All the sentient beings are being cruelly treated and unnecessarily slaughtered.
And all who find life meaningless.
May you be free of physical pain.
May you be free of mental distress.
May you be liberated of all your suffering.
radiating our care and compassion to all beings in all directions may all beings be free of physical pain may all beings be free of mental distress may all beings be liberated of all their sufferings
Thinking to mind now some moments of joyfulness, happiness that we've experienced today.
And rejoicing in that.
May I be joyful.
May I be ever more joyful.
May I experience the bliss of liberation.
Bringing to mind someone we know who has good cause to be joyful.
And wish them greater joy.
May you be joyful.
May you be ever more joyful.
May you experience the bliss of awakening.
that all those at this moment who are happy and content with their lives who are enjoying the warmth of all levels of friendship enjoying the delights of art nature sport hobbies and so on who find their work meaningful who enjoy the fruitfulness of their spiritual practice and who rejoice in the success of others may you be joyful
May you be ever more joyful.
May you experience the bliss of Nirvana.
radiating our joy to all beings in all directions may all beings be joyful may all beings be ever more joyful may all beings experience the bliss of libana
Allowing these words to flow through us.
If you are wise and want to reach the state of peace, then develop these qualities.
Be upright, responsible, gentle and humble.
Be easily content and need only a few things.
Be less busy and live simply.
Guard the senses and be modest.
Do not be attached to only a few people, to the exclusion of others.
Do not do the slightest thing that a wise person could blame you for.
And be constantly thinking, may all beings be happy.
Whatever living beings there are, be they weak or strong, big or small, large or slender, living nearby or far away, those who've already been born and those who've yet to be born.
May all beings, without exception, be happy.
Let no one deceive another or disdain any.
Do not wish harm to anyone, not even when you're angry.
Just as a mother would protect her only child at the risk of her own life, let the warmth of your heart go out to all beings.
Let your love and goodwill spread throughout the whole world, above and below, without boundary, ill will or hatred.
Whether you are standing, walking, sitting or lying down, so long as you are awake, you should develop this affectionate mindfulness.
This, they say, is the noblest way to live.
And if you do not fall into unskillful ways, but live well and develop insight and are no longer attached to all the desires of the senses, then truly you'll never need to be reborn into this world again.
So feel free to join me in the chanting or offer these blessings.
May you be safe, well and happy.
May you live contented, in harmony,
with the world.
Santhendriyocchani bhagocchā bhagavokuleśu anānuhīdho na cākūdāṃ samācārekeñcīye nā viṇyu pāre upavādehu sukhi nā vākemi nā hāntu sābeśatā bhavāntu sukhi tātā
yekechi panabhuta-thi tasa-vata-vada-va-ana-vasesam tiga-vayema-hantavam vimarasakalukatulam dita-vayema-aditaye ca-dureva-santi-avudhure
bhūtā vāsaṁ bhāveśi vāsābeśātā bhāvantu sukhi tātā na paro bharaṁ nīkūpētā na tīmānyatā kathā cīnenkeṣu viyārosaṇṇāpati gāsañjā nānyamānyāsātukāṁ gīcēyā madhāyatā niyāṁ kūtā
ayusai kaputanga nurake evampi saba bhutesu manasambhavaye aparimanam metenca sabalokasni manasambhavaye aparimanam udanga doca tiri anca asampatanga veranga sapatam
Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji
May all beings be happy.
Very good.
Don't forget, from now till we fall asleep is also part of our practice.
Make it simple, take it easy, stay with the one who knows.
Put something lovely in the heart, slip away into deep oblivion, only to wake to make the best of the day.
May I wish you all a very peaceful night.